I can win this believe it or not but the
clock situation is you know it's getting
closer to level that's good news for
farouza who's up a pawn and I think he's
he wants to win this game he's looking
at Magnus and saying you're not quick
enough to hang with me
wow wow them words would never come out
of my mouth like I mean unbelievable you
know but right now it is working in
farooza's favorite he had two games by
flag and again it doesn't matter how you
get it it matters did you get it done
right so he does oh wait he he moved and
he may not be getting it done here baby
boy and let's see let's see the speed
from from Magnus he's not putting the
king in check at all he needs to put
that King exactly the internet
one
oh and Perugia left his yeah he got him